we define romantic love as an intense
desire for another with the expectation
that is going to live this is going to
persist into the future and that
distinguishes it from lust which is
generally fleeting and also from more
companionship love which doesn't have
that intensity of desire that you want
to possess the other in some in some way
often it's characterized by some sort of
irrationality not doing what a rational
person would do in those circumstances
buying a large gift when you really
don't have the money or going out to a
really nice restaurant or making that
that extra sign of one's love that you
hope will will attract the other and so
really it's it's a bit of craziness
romantic love we're a little bit off
kilter when we're in love and that's the
way we talk about it it's like we're
underwater in some way or where we're
overwhelmed by love crazy and love
well there were there are some clear
evolutionary advantages to following him
in love and especially for pair-bonding
a male-female bond and let's think back
you know 20 30 thousand years ago when
our ancestors are living on the savannas
in Africa human infants are incredibly
helpless and it's very hard for one
person to take care of an infant and
also gather food and hunt food and run
from predators and so having some sort
of core familial group makes lots of
sense and so there are evolutionary
psychologists and biologists who would
say we evolved a propensity for romantic
love to create families so that it's not
just the mother taking care of the child
but a father as well mothers have this
natural need to take care of Jodha the
child comes from the mother has to feed
and breastfeed with the mother fathers
are less inherently attached to the
child and so there is a theory that
males evolved this propensity to fall in
love so they would stick with their
their partners
an evolutionary biologists would say
yeah we have this propensity that's
evolved that creates all of these
positive side effects for us socially
creating families for example but
sometimes those propensity scan can go
out of control we seem to have a
propensity to eat fatty foods for
example and yet in the society in which
we live that's not so adaptive as it was
ten thousand years ago we should have
eaten fat every chance we got and now we
have to sort of fight against ourselves
and resist all of that fat and so it's
it doesn't necessarily it's not
necessarily a contradiction that we
could have evolved a I keep saying
propensity we could have evolved a
propensity for romantic love and yet
it's it's counter adaptive sometimes to
but you do find suicides for example and
that's about as dramatic as it gets a
number of cases in India for example of
young men and young women in arranged
marriages are going into arranged
marriage and committing suicide rather
than spend their life without their
truly beloved
you